human bodies or what is left of them
remains of children men and women police
in the southern Nigerian state of ABIA
believe they were taken hostage from
their cars on the nearby Highway that
leads to the oil Rich towns taken at
gunpoint to the nearby Forest by cattle
market those who work there deny being
involved in the attack we are lot AB
citizens and you can see we do our good
businesses here we and the host
community
and the security that have been here
will work hand to hand together and make
sure peace returns normally back toi
entirely the captives who could afford
to pay the ransom were freed those who
could not were killed their vital organs
like eyes kidneys even the heart stolen
and sold to
traffickers Chuck's onua escaped from
his abductors after being robbed they
make me drive all the money I had in my
account so the trauma the suffering
whatever is still there for me as I talk
to you I have not still fully recovered
police have recovered at least 80 bodies
and arrested three suspects a spokesman
for the state's Governor hopes the
arrest will reassure business owners and
bring Justice to the family I think it's
held us down like I said first of all it
used to be a 6 to 6 6:00 a.m. to 6:00
p.m. economy with wanted to push that to
a point where people can now have night
life haunted by the discoveries the
cattle market is slowly coming back to
life but there is an eerie sense that
deep in this Forest are more bodies
waiting to be Unearthed Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer